lassen sie mich noch ein letztes wort
sagen weil ich glaube dass wir in diesem
tag auch offen sein sollten damit dass
es inhaltlichen dissens in der afg gibt
ich finde wir sollten diesen nicht tot
schweigen weil das genau das was sie von
der gesellschaft auffordern dass eine
offene kontroverse geführt wird
die afg von 2013 hat den klaren anspruch
vertreten und so war es auch bis 2015 am
ende schnell regierungsfähig zu werden
das ist weiterhin mein anspruch eine
anarchische partei wie es in den
vergangenen wochen das eine oder andere
mal zu hören war die die afg sei die
kann in der opposition erfolgreich sein
aber sie kann eben dem wähler kein
glaubwürdiges angebot für eine
regierungsübernahme machen und das ist
der grund meine damen und herren unter
anderem in meinem anspruch verbunden
dass ich aktiv gestalten möchte und
realpolitik im guten sinne einer
konservativen politik machen werde
für mich nach langer überlegung zu
entscheiden dass ich derart d fraktion
im deutschen bundestag nicht angehören
werde
meine damen und herren ich bitte um
verständnis dass ich dazu jetzt auch
keine weiteren fragen beantwortet sie
haben sicherlich noch viele fragen ich
werde im foyer auch noch für wenige
nachfragen bereitstehen ich möchte mich
bei meinen kollegen bedanken bei 12
wahrlich seiner download- und bei
gebäuden und werde jetzt diesen raum
verlassen
dankeschön
alle partner dass alte petri das finde
ich ein faires verhalten hier auch
gegenüber den kollegen leid aber sie
nutzen das forum der
bundespressekonferenz mit der welt
versetzen und verschwinden also insofern
missbilligen wir dieses verhalten
ausdrücklich